una inesperada noticia que cambia el
rumbo de chad horas después de que la
comisión electoral anunciara la
reelección del presidente chadiano
idriss deby itno de 68 años el ejército
informó del fallecimiento del mandatario
y máximo comandante militar del país a
causa de las heridas sufridas en el
frente de combate contra los rebeldes
según el ejército
de idriss deby itno acaba de exhalar su
último aliento defendiendo la nación
soberana en el campo de batalla lección
de batalla
el consejo militar de transición
garantiza la independencia nacional la
integridad territorial la unidad
nacional el respeto de los tratados y
acuerdos internacionales
acorán camacho no la asamblea nacional
el una asamblea nacional y el gobierno
fueron disueltos y fue promulgado una
carta de transición por el presidente
del consejo militar de transición de
transición según el portavoz del
ejército el hijo del mandatario mahamat
idriss deby dirigir al consejo militar
de transición durante los próximos 18
meses y no el presidente del parlamento
como dicta la constitución las
autoridades han decretado un toque de
queda nocturno y el cierre de todas las
fronteras
pero en las calles del país se vive un
clima de incertidumbre según los
resultados preliminares de los
disputados comicios del pasado 11 de
abril boicoteados por la oposición el
mandatario contaría con casi el 80% de
los votos para gobernar durante otros
seis años
los rumores que corren sobre el consejo
de transición me dan la impresión de que
hay informaciones falsas
de formación ya se habla de disolver el
parlamento eso es delicado tenemos una
constitución que seguir así que para mí
diría que fue un golpe de estado lo
mataron
idriss deby fue un fiel aliado de
occidente en la lucha contra el
yihadismo en la región y especialmente
de francia donde realizó su formación
militar llegó al poder hace 31 años
reconocido como un brillante estratega
militar gobernó con mano de hierro el
país resistiendo a numerosos intentos de
golpe de estado